befriedigendes sexleben viagra für
frauen und virus gelangte in das
netzwerk einer sicherheitsfirma
das sind nur drei der heutigen fünf
themen in den klicks um top five news
ich bin sagt peter christoph muss heute
auf dem web video preis dass wir
vertreten heute noch mal und wir fangen
mit erst news ein team des massachusetts
general hospital in boston hat eine
amputierte raffen boote erst in ihre
einzelteile zerlegt und dann neu
zusammengesetzt jeder hat seine zelle
herrmann mit zellen einer anderen rasse
wieder herstellen können das verfahren
sei sogar auch auf den menschen
übertragbar
die forscher lösten die einzigen zelle
mit hilfe eines lösungsmittels nach
mehreren tagen bestückten sie das jetzt
bloße skelett mit lebendigen zellen fast
alle nervenbahnen muskelstränge und blut
verläufe habe man wieder herstellen
können um die muskulatur zu stärken
reiste man diese mit elektrischen
impulsen bis die pfote wieder ganz war
vergingen circa 14 tage
die quote hatte dann sogar eine derartig
starke ausgeprägten muskulatur dass man
diese mit der einer baby rate
vergleichen kann in der heutigen
transplantationsmedizin hat man immer
wieder probleme mit der heftigen
immunreaktion des körpers
das sei bei diesem verfahren aber nicht
mehr so die alten zellen werden ja
sozusagen durch die selbigen ersetzt
beim menschen ist diese verfahren zwar
denkbar aber noch lange nicht in sicht
zu komplex der aufbau der menschlichen
anatomie die die cellular easy rung und
repro polarisierung könnte
transplantationen wesentlich
verträglicher machen das größte problem
in der transplantationsmedizin das
spenderorgan bleibt jedoch bestehen
wurde das kann auch dieses verfahren
nicht durchgeführt werden
das pentagon ist größter kunde des f-35
bis 2065 wollen sie bis zu eine billion
dollar investieren
ganze 2447 stück möchte das pentagon dem
lockheed martin unternehmen abnehmen ein
einzelner jet des typs f-35 kostet 160
millionen dollar in den vergangenen
tagen liefen die ersten gefecht übungen
2006 erklärte der damalige amerikanische
präsident george hw bush den f 35
tarnkappen jet zu seinem liebsten stück
so wie damals weissert aber noch heute
jede menge fehler auf die wohl
bezeichneten fehler waren sichtbarkeit
auf dem radar schlechter sicht aus dem
cockpit kopfstütze zu groß und das
400.000 dollar hellem display welt
teilweise ganz aus ein auf dem radar
sichtbare tarnkappen chef der eigentlich
auf dem radar unsichtbar sein sollte ist
sozusagen nicht zu gebrauchen
auf der nellis air force base in nevada
sollte der test zeigen was er wirklich
kann über 5000 soldaten waren dort im
einsatz
neben den kmk tagen cup in chat sollen
auch noch andere flugzeuge des f-35
gebaut werden der 500 jahren kampfjet f
35b ein senkrechtstarter und der 35 c
ein flugzeugträger das pentagon wird
wohl noch vor der anschaffung die
ergebnisse des gestrigen ausgelaufenen
green flag test man übers abwarten
10.000 menschen wurden zu ihrer
zufriedenheit mit ihrem sexleben befragt
über 50 prozent seien der befragung nach
unzufrieden
die befragung wurde von der online
partnerbörse elite partner und dem
marktforschungsinstitut fittkau & maaß
durchgeführt das ist mal wieder eine von
vielen sechs studien auch diese brachte
er traurigere ergebnisse zum vorschein
sondern ab dem dreißigsten lebensjahr
schwindet die begeisterung über das
sexleben enormen besonders stark wenn
die person eine feste partnerin oder
einen festen partner haben nur 554 der
liierten männer und 47 prozent
delegierten frauen haben nach eigenen
angaben ein zufriedenstellendes sexleben
wer eine beziehung führt hat also ein
schlechter sex leben so scheint es zu
sein denn jeder vierte mann ist mit
seiner sexuellen aktivität in seiner
beziehung unzufrieden
doch warum in vielen beziehungen wird
das thema sechs häufig im stillen
genossen kaum einer spricht offen und
direkt
das thema sechs anstellungen sexuelle
praktiken eigenen vorlieben wenn kaum
erwähnt das führt dann zu
unbefriedigenden sex und enttäuschungen
im sex leben bei eltern von kindern wird
die stille noch viel viel größer viele
paare mit kindern haben oft sogar nicht
mal ein mal pro monat geschlechtsverkehr
singles haben vergleichsweise viel sechs
teilweise sogar mindestens einmal pro
woche
viele werden auch als sogenannte mingels
bezeichnet offiziell nennen die sich
singe verkehren aber dennoch regelmäßig
mit einer einzigen bestimmten person und
das auch sexuell
das hängt auch mit dem wachsenden
sexuellen selbstbewusstsein von singles
zusammen so dieser fischbach eine
diplom-psychologin dass in russland
angesiedelte unternehmen kaspersky
kümmert sich schon seit jahren um die
sicherheitsbedürfnisse ihrer kunden
jetzt sind sie sozusagen ihr eigener
kunde geworden
anfang des jahres fanden sie einen virus
auf ihren eigenen rechnern allerdings
seite wie auch schon monatelang im
system gewesen
keiner hat es bemerkt der schädling
weise ähnlichkeiten zur doku auf 2011
sagte dieser
für große aufregung nach aussagen eines
kaspersky analyst hatte der
programmierer von doku damals besonders
geopolitische ziele im auge der doku 2.0
wir von vielen im unternehmen jetzt
genannt wird habe sich eher für die
technologien des kaspersky lab sichere
betriebssysteme und aktuelle projekte
der firma interessiert
genaue angaben zu den schafen des virus
gibt kaspersky noch nicht im auge jedoch
haben sie bereits den israelischen staat
dezente spuren würden darauf hinweisen
dass ein unternehmen das für sicherheit
steht ein solcher vorfall öffentlich
macht das nicht gerade üblich kaspersky
äußert sich offen und transparent über
die geschehnisse
man gebe aber keinerlei informationen
die ihre kunden gefährden können
die sicherheitsbehörden britanniens und
russland seien bereits informiert worden
auch microsoft weiß bescheid da die
angreifer eine schwachstelle im windows
system ausmachten und zu ihren gunsten
nutzen die der virus auf ihre systeme
gelangt ist habe sich wohl schon geklärt
man hat einen mitarbeiter als auslöser
ausgemacht er aber eine gut getarnte e
mail von den angreifern mit einem
ungefährlich erscheinenden anhang
geöffnet im anhang der virus
das fg gremium der us
arzneimittelbehörde stimmt der profi
beim serie viele batterien das ähnlich
wie viagra für den mann ein lust
steigern das medikament für die frau
bisher führte jede überprüfung des
medikaments dazu dass das nicht erlaubt
wurde und nicht auf dem markt erscheinen
durfte jetzt habe das medikament aber
positive ergebnisse bei dem wohl
wichtigsten gremium der medizin den usa
erzielt ganz auf den markt geschafft hat
es viele batterien deswegen noch nicht
aber das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich nur
noch eine formalität wie batterien ist
in der medizin besser als
antidepressivum bekannt es lindert die
konzentration des serotonins im körper
und steigert die das dopamin dopamin ist
das allbekannte glückshormons serotonin
ist ein was die lust angeblicher
ungünstiges verloren dopamin könne in
höheren maßen die libido der frau an
regen getestet wurde das auch schon
frauen die viel berlin einnahmen konnten
sehr positive entwicklungen in ihrem
sexleben verspüren
für mich war der effekt nicht bescheiden
sondern bedeutend so amanda parish
boehringer ingelheim ein deutscher
pharmakonzerne war eigentümer des
patents für flibanserin entwickelt wurde
es nämlich genau von diesen konzern an
den jetzigen besitzer eine amerikanische
firma braut form erzeugt titels gelang
das patent durch ein verkauf nachdem das
medikament das erste mal bei dem
prüfungsverfahren durchgefallen ist
verkaufte der deutsche konzern sein
patent ob der sich jetzt ärgert wie mit
wissenschaftlichen tipps eine
potenzielle partnerin oder ein
potenzieller partner beeindruckt werden
kann erfahrt ihr im video hier oben
forscher verraten die besten dating
tipps so einfach zu blöd kommt hier
unten und was sind denn eure besten
dating tipps die müssen jetzt nicht
unbedingt wissenschaftlich fundiert sein
aber schreiben sie uns doch einfach mal
gerne in die kommentare dann wünsche ich
noch eine schöne rest woche ein schönes
wochenende und bis dann